this discussion is between cristiano
ronaldo and mohamed salah for the
right-wing premier league
combined 11. mohammed salah has
literally come in the last five six
years and taken over the premier league
goal scoring charts how many goals
three golden boots in the last four
against the likes of them so european
cops premier league one season i'm
accepting all of the three p as well
eva i'm accepting all of that but i'm
not accepting it on the right wing
right guys you're here today to agree on
an 11 for the premier league all-time
era i'm glad it's not current i was just
going to say
i love the way you guys are for all time
premier league but it is what it is you
got some talking today so i'm explaining
where do you want to begin we're going
straight in not even no friendly chit
chat or nothing
friendly chit chat and even when you
know it and then come on yeah it's not
easy right yeah it won't be very
friendly if we move to the center mids
oh my god
i i think you're going to get your heart
broken here you know and it's early on
it's going to be the first time it's
early on in this show but if we're doing
two midfielders yeah you can only be
keen on scrolls i'm sorry
stevie gerrard there's absolutely no
need to be sorry because the beauty of
my man the beauty of my man is he
literally can play in any of those
positions so either way my man's getting
in so you're not breaking this hole we
can't because if we just start taking
wingers then he's taking
ronaldo giggs salah so
we can't limit
we can't put him out why then the the
suggestion with obviously
mr judge's permission will be a possible
formation change because literally i
think he knows steven gerrard has to be
in this team he has a chat i don't know
where he's gonna have to because if
you've got roy keane you've got the
leader you've got a player who's got
great passing ability defensive box to
box earlier on in his career
won it three times in a row the premier
league title that is won the european
cup poor scholes won it three times in a
row on two occasions won two european
cops
they changed the game and as a
partnership um
at the end of the day i'm not going to
argue with keane because everyone has a
favorite from even a rival that you know
walks into any areas 11. and i'm humble
enough to say roy keane walks into every
area of all time 11. yeah but i think
adam's got to be a bit flexible and say
stephen gerrard walks into every era so
you think so you think it's got to be
keen and instead of skulls you've got to
go i think keane and gerald would be i
think that's what he's saying if we do a
team here and kingdom skulls aren't in
it then maybe we do that
so you i look i'm willing to go for a
formation change as long as all parties
agree to be fair gerrard is one of about
two players that makes it in for
liverpool wow
so to be fair and i think if you want a
formation channel i think scotland adam
is okay with it and i think scholes
doesn't get into the conversation when
it comes to gerard because look at the
end of the day
your greatest manager
mr man united alex ferguson speaks of
steven gerrard as an absolute unreal
player that doesn't mean he doesn't i'd
say listen
you really reckon if he had the chance
to steinstein gerard he wouldn't that
people i think and he wouldn't get into
he spoke about gerardo and keane left
not when keem was there right we're
gonna have to get to an answer here we
can all argue about this all day i don't
think there's much of an argument i
don't know you should argue no we've got
three fields change the formation yeah
we're willing to go with four through
three i'm willing to be flexible there
yeah okay adam so that means gerard
keane scores it does we've got
liverpool or keen gerard scores whatever
either way we've got the three
midfielders
i think that makes amazing sense
give me two red bad boys come on you've
got two of them you do the honors mate
and uh
there's your one you know i must mention
we've got a liverpool away kit so it's
white which is why it can't have two red
no that's right no problem
there we go good start
i think it's
a good opportunity to move swiftly on
to this position right here the right
wing
yeah or david beckham's position it's a
big debate anytime too really
like like you're really going to look me
in the eye
and say david beckham or christian are
on the right wing like
mr judge even is going to look at think
and think christian ronaldo played his
best football on this side on that side
you're just throwing names in for the
sake of man united i believe because i
think again
foreign name come on for the sake david
beckham sure in 99 best player in the
world won a treble
won the league three times in the you
know role
he was see i'm going to be hit with this
i'm going to be hit with this and then
we have a shot of an adult 40 plus goals
in a season a ballon d'or european cup a
premier league title adam not from there
is it though that's you know they're
both sides
all across the front three
grizz i want
well i think he's deflecting he knows
he's deflecting yeah you talk about the
left wing because that's reserved for
one man
i think how many man did you want to
reserve here like i don't know you're
just reserving everywhere like it's like
you guys have been done
it's like this is pre-planned before me
what's going on here you haven't
mentioned the player you're going for
right-wing i don't want to mention him
that's how obvious it is i want you to
see
come on bro i'm going to say it and i
think we're going to have grizzes
backing here this discussion is between
cristiano ronaldo and mohamed salah for
the right-wing premier league
combined 11. is that correct that's oh
yeah we'll go with ronaldo that is
absolutely correct but i think but the
beauty of it is i can't
argue against ronaldo in this team but i
most certainly can argue about ronaldo
on the right wing as opposed to marisa
because ronaldo done his work on the
left this guy is just from a left wing a
right wing position guys you have an
argument there from the right wing he's
just won three out of four ballon uh
golden boots from the right-wing role i
understand what you're saying ronaldo
has one and done left that less sorry
from the right wing position
on the left no no we're on both sides
man right wing yeah other's lead and
where's brown on the right but he was
mainly known for that
and now he plays at striker so there is
another left side bruce has a point he
played on the left
adam three golden boots in the back
against the
so european court so premier league one
season i'm accepting all of the three p
as well
even i am accepting all of that but i'm
not accepting it on the right wing we
could possibly contemplate putting them
on the left um
i see so what you're what you're willing
to say is
if we take the right wing roll and give
it to moses and if we put ronaldo on the
left we could put back i think i think
there's an argument for ronaldo on the
left when we get to it realistically
it's beckham versus seller and i think
salah wipes the floor as the jaw as the
judge i'm gonna mention in their prime
ronaldo was a real madrid that's where
he won most his champions leagues he's
gonna let him land he's got a very good
point
he's got a very good seller in his prime
is winning premier league's champions
all the cups it's a voting personal
accolades different story we can get on
to that
prime or not doesn't matter the truth is
up here and sellers primes
but we're not going to ronaldo at united
was still above salah do you get with it
with the arguments not going i
understand i get where the arguments go
both arguments right i think there's
space for ronaldo in the whole front
three if we're talking for right-wing no
but we're not taking this away from
rooney i'm tonight
why to ahead mr you're thinking
let's focus on this because this is very
this is difficult because on one hand if
we get ronaldo in here where else do we
get liverpool anywhere else this is a
premier league we're talking about carl
mark we're going to get on to that
i think we've got to give this one oh
there's a bit of biasedness already here
from the judge i'm fighting a lost cause
here
and i think we will continue david
beckham but currently i'm telling you
now the comments are going to be flying
and they're going to be it's coming out
you're doing the honours right wing spot
thank you sir grizz i mean i don't know
that red chip winner winner chicken
dinner this ain't a sympathy vote though
i'm not happy do i not like that all
right get a red chip out come on no well
we'll get to it
yeah let's get to it yeah you want to go
straight to it because shawna ronaldo
over there you want to go on to the left
so the thing is see the thing is i feel
as though you've
you've just fought with me from
should have been over here
and ryan gets potentially he absolutely
shouldn't have been over there but i am
absolutely admitting he should be here
yeah so that's how it works right we've
got to fit space for ronaldo the striker
position is another argument i think
it's fair to say i've given you yeah
yeah we've agreed so the wingers are now
mohamed salah
and cristiano ronaldo there you go you
do the honours both had 40 goal seasons
to be fair to
winger's complete striker position i
feel like there's going to be bit of
argument there's a lot of options
there's only one place it's a tussle
you've got andy call obviously
you've got wayne rooney rude vanessa
eric cantona those are the four that are
in the front never mind who you got and
i like the names the names he's brought
off are you know he's routed off a few
names and i can round off a few names
that may have given him a hard time in
the past as i can i can mention michael
owen robbie fowler a certain fernando
torres
you know luis suarez who may not be
everyone's cup of tea off the pitch into
or even on the pitch
in certain situations but in terms of uh
talent yeah when he wanted to turn it on
he was better than anyone in terms of i
mean the 13 14 season i think every new
neutral witnessed in that season for me
still the single most amazing season
from a forward for a player yeah and
you've got a good argument he's an
amazing player and that that season he
was unreal but ultimately what happened
at the end happened the one you have to
go with and he should be in any premier
league all-time eleven is wayne rooney
wayne rooney
i knew you'd go for this it's hard to
fight an argument against wayne rooney
during the premier league era i think
his eight league titles yeah the
european cup
um
all sorts of different goals he was a
playmaker he was a striker when he had
to be the main man he would be the main
man when ronaldo was floating across the
front three would sacrifice himself i
mean if you're looking at a team player
you're looking at a footballer you're
looking at the level of goals and
everything wayne rooney is a complete
player chris have you got anything he's
a complete premier league player wayne
rooney so again wayne rooney is one of
those players that i do rate in terms of
a player of course the rivalry aside
i'm not gonna sit here and wayne rooney
is not a great player absolutely
fantastic player
i think it's not a foregone conclusion
as as
as used to seemingly are making it i
think louis harris was a literally a
genius on the pitch
people are looking at the walls even if
you look at what you did in barcelona i
was just going to say he went on one of
the few players that have left liverpool
and went on and to prove and not only at
barcelona athletico the problem is we're
talking about premier league and that's
not in the premier league sure but he
didn't do bad in the premier league
while he was here 70 goals in 111 that's
amazing
goals in the premier league from wayne
rooney as well by the way insane levels
of course not a lot in longevity
look i tell you where i tell you what
adam i'm fair longevity-wise and
everything that you brought to the table
i accept and wayne rooney was no
i think it's like gerard you know if we
looked at this team at the end and wayne
rooney went on it
you'd be like her yeah that's a good
point something's gone wrong there we
have one striker
and that is going to wayne rooney i'm
sorry i'm sorry grizz
it's only right man another
is it premier league era i hope there's
a vote
get down in the comments
we've done a lot of forward talking
we've got the front three settled
midfield complete i think it's time for
a solid centre-back duo a combined
premier league era liverpool versus
manchester united we've got to agree on
two
if i was going to include liverpool
players i've got two of four
real ferdinand i think is the greatest
premier league defender ever
nemanja vidic who is sublime next to him
those two with van dassar evra
wrote record after record the most clean
sheets in the premier league era so
you've got real ferdinand nemanja vidic
yapstan
won the treble was amazing the only
thing with yap sam is he didn't have the
longevity in the premier league and he
went on to do great things at ac manager
and then virgil van dyke
for obvious reasons i think it has to be
two of them for personally grizz what's
your thinking um
i'm thinking um it's one of those again
it's one of those decisions where
you stick virgil van dyke in there
and then you say who partners him
because
because this guy is is just a phenomenal
phenomenal center back in every single
way
uh rio ferdinand
again one of my favorite center backs in
terms of putting rivalries aside yap
stam for me
was
was an absolute but he had it he had it
all he literally had it all so you think
stam should be in this team i i i i'd
struggle not to pick a stam in this team
seriously yeah because that's how much i
rated him yep stan
yeah okay fine so are we agreeing on the
first position being stan we'll get on
today
no no because it seems like you're
you're supporting him
who he's saying alongside okay you know
what i was going with this right i just
want to put my admiration for yap stamp
out there yeah yeah yeah absolutely yeah
yeah no exactly i think
i think there was no way
two players premier guerra yeah look
look virgil van hack is
you know the term rolls royce of a
defender just throwing that willy-nilly
at every guy that can just that's nice
you know they started calling they
started calling harry maguire rolls
royce do you know what i mean like
you're doing that yeah i'm sure i can
find a clip from leicester yeah i can
find a clip somewhere after we've done
there's a fridge that's not now when it
comes don't make fridge
when he ran out with the ball a few
times he was like oh rolls royce come on
man he's like a
truck man come on rolls royce virgil van
dyke
he's a nail grace i've got a question
for you so is he the best centre-back
for liverpool in the premier league
there's not your number one argument
there's no shadow of a doubt i couldn't
i couldn't see behind rio and samuel i
can suggest okay
i've given admiration to staff you think
virgil van dyke is behind
the best defender in premier league era
rio i think
like
but we have to agree on two here we're
always a dead center i think rio i think
rio should be the only guarantee i think
by the way for me is a guarantee i think
by the time virgil van dyke retired i
think rio would admit yeah do you know
what he had more attribution better than
me
i'm just saying real fernando village
had the most clean sheets in premier
league are consecutive
yeah because stan for me was the thing
is rio ferdinand it's like i said stand
on right now rio ferdinand if you if you
think and work with me rio ferdinand was
born as the as the as the church you
already was winning leagues he was
really very successful another time real
ferdinand when rio ferdinand came he was
the icing on the cake right
virgil van dyke
is our cake man we're fasting otherwise
if we didn't bring in virgil i'm going
to conclude this we've had our
discussions i think both of you got very
good arguments so i'm going to give you
both
but
as i said i had admired
so here we go i have to say who that is
i'm going to say now rio ferdinand
virgil van dijk that is the center well
that's if we don't worry yeah you might
want to start no but he might have
wanted to
nah now rio has to be in rio he's the
greatest premier league and so does
virgil van dyke really put up a good
thing but we all fell in love yapster
are what they think van dyke is but
we'll leave the comments to the side
left back
i think i know what we're going to be
arguing here but adam introduce your
player it's either dennis erwin or
patrice evra
and i'll go for dennis early really yeah
i'll go for dennis owen he's part of one
of my favorite manchester united teams
again another part of why we won the
treble
you know three titles in a row
um goals assists penalties free kicks
and a solid defender as well
chris who's the player you put forward
for left back um a certain andrew
robertson brought from whole everyone
laughed and scoffed at the signing
thinking why are we buying and a seven
million left back from whole
but hey who's laughing now he's gone on
to become possibly possibly the best
left back in europe i think out of any
fallback here
any united fallback dennis irving has to
be i i'm i'm i'm looking forward like
adam was looking forward in these areas
early on yes i've learned from your
tactics right so i'm looking forward
right and check this out sure
i'm gonna give in because dennis irwin
had the edge in terms of
set pieces and free kicks because i
remember yeah he was a phenomenal
free-kick well we're different
generations so you've probably seen more
of dennis than i have exactly i'm
i thought you put up a great argument
for andy robertson he's won a lot he's
been an incredible talent there's an
argument for me the best left back in
the world right now but you've given in
take the left back roll lovely thank you
dennis irwin i'm going to go watch some
highlights later you need to check him
out let's move over to the other full
back side i think there's a big argument
for you yeah chris surely you're putting
down a trend the thing is this is why
i'm hoping this was a tactical
vote adam mentioned something earlier on
and i liked what he used the argument he
used i'm gonna use it not against him
because in the end he's going to agree
with copying tactics real ferdinand he
said revolutionized that centre-back
playing rock in terms of how he played
it and the original rolls-royce he
referred to him as
i think it's fair to say that this fella
here young trent alexander the great
arnold absolutely revolutionized the way
fallback is is seen this guy is is a
footballing icon a playmaker a creator
probably one of the most
complex ways he plays this game from a
right back situation that's insane my
one's gary neville in it yeah um 11
league titles i think it is he was a
great leader
you know he wasn't as sexy as trent
arnold's alexander ronald in terms of
what he did on the football pitch and
you know the passing and all that
although he did contribute a lot in
terms of assists overlapping overlapping
david beckham for club and country that
relationship was amazing yeah um but i
think we got we've got to be fair the
numbers that trent is putting up at the
moment as well
i'll i'll read it can i suggest
something you must admit if we're
talking accolades trophies
if you're talking trophies then then
gary never was going to win yeah can i
so i'm surprised he wouldn't put up an
argument for that no i could but i think
even gary neville would possibly put
trent ahead of him therefore as the
judge i'm going to give you this thank
you
enjoy the right back roll you've got the
right flank
alexander liverpool love the right flank
united have the left
and there's only one position left
goalkeeper we currently have
four for liverpool
and i think we've got six for manchester
united so it's about right though isn't
it i mean you think it is as an era if
you look at the premier league when you
do an all-time premier league
like there's even some united players
that could feel hard on buying to not be
there or or definitely there hmm do i
mean so what's your argument for
goalkeeper
so i got schmeichel or vandasar
no de gea
no you could make an argument for de gea
but i think
schmeichel of anderson yeah they're the
greatest keepers that manchester united
have had
i think you've got an argument for both
i've i've got i do you [ __ ] leave
because this is it schmeichel didn't she
might vandalize cartwheel for against us
when playing for c
so we still hold that against schmeichel
check this one out guys can we do
something
probably more of a modern day goalkeeper
can we do something different here and
let me decide his because i'm going to
continue no but check this out because
i'm going to be fair right so alison
is an absolute beast and a monster lucky
goalkeeper but
just like we spoke about revolutionizing
this position yeah and then rio and then
we're talking about other positions
peter schmeichel for me revolutionized
the goalkeeping position he was the
original one-to-one member i think he's
one of the greatest ever and
he's
usually he's usually my man united the
fact that he started the fact that he
the fact that he started celebrating
against him obviously
right
but yeah peter was only one last season
at the end of it he won the trouble as
well yeah
i can't it wasn't about when he went
there fine it was about what he did when
they scored against us right yeah they
never rate that but alison look as i
said it's very difficult because of the
guy hasn't stopped playing yet and we
don't know how much more he can go on to
win because he's still relatively young
for a goalkeeper he's probably got
another five seven five to seven years
as a goalkeeper minimum maybe more do
you get what i'm saying so it's very
difficult to put him in that argument
right as of now so i'm being fair yep
but i just think schmeichel and maybe
it's because of ruining myself as well
maybe because maybe because schmeichel
ruined my childhood like watching
those games i think michael was a
monster i think we're going to go with
schmeichel yeah
yeah we all agree i'm good with that as
the judge
to finish it off
peter schmeichel see the thing seven
four seven four in a premier league the
thing is right i could feel aggrieved
about this so many red dots and
obviously because you try to
when you do this you see man united now
and it's so difficult to imagine how
they've managed to get seven players in
but obviously we're going back a few
decades could have had nine there's lots
of discussions i'm sure the comments are
gonna be going well during this video
guys it's a pleasure to have you on nice
one i think we've got one great team
thank you i'm very happy to be here and
uh yeah lovely seven for united
four for liverpool
it's been a pleasure
[Music]
can we do this in another decade where
we'll have about where we live
eight two or something
you'd have to you'd have to actually win
a league again yeah
you think he's a midfielder in it
scotland i genuinely
why how he had no pace he was dead small
he wasn't that he wasn't that good
yeah he couldn't tackle save his life